hey my name's Sebastian Maniscalco check
out my new Netflix special stay hungry
what is the grossest thing you like to
eat that you hide from others out of
shame Auntie Anne's pretzel I don't know
if that's gross but I sneaked it when I
go to the bathroom at the airport and my
wife's not working how long can you last
on the run after robbing a bank about 31
seconds be caught coming right out of
the bank
I have no criminal skills whatsoever
would you rather go to heaven or become
a ghost on earth after you die I'm going
ghost all the way there's a lot of
people I wouldn't mind flying into their
living room to see what they're talking
about Oh God
like to know what my father says when
I'm not around not really just in the
moment here as we're doing it the one
celebrity birthday party you would want
to attend I think I wouldn't mind going
to a Beyonce birthday party to see what
type of money they got yeah I think you
know I think you would get like an
outfit in the mail if you went to their
their party this is this is what you
have to wear do you think there's more
porn stars or murders in the world I
gotta go I gotta go murderers I think
there's a lot of people out there
looking to commit a murder how long
would it take you to drink all of the
water in the above-ground pool fresh
water no chemicals I've been known to
guzzle a lot of water at one time pretty
quickly
yeah I'd say good I could knock it out
in a month what is your best [ __ ]
excuse you said to a girl to avoid
texting or hanging out with her I don't
know I'm on an important call
[Laughter]
if you can get one historical figure to
have a twitter account who would it be
to get one historical figure at a time
Michael Jackson
[Laughter]
you